retour en france avec cette étude de
l'insee sur l'impact d'internet il y a
quelques années vous vous en souvenez
les spécialistes annonçaient l'arrivée
d'une nouvelle société en réseau et bien
au vu des chiffres on est encore loin du
compte les deux tiers des français ne se
sont jamais connectés selon cette étude
internet qui reste largement réservée
aux catégories dites supérieures
laurence de chef bruno livertout en
informatique il y a les hermétiques tout
juste de me mettre au minitel alors si
vous ne parlez des ordinateurs et
d'internet
on va attendre quelques années je pense
mais aussi les allergiques
ça m'a jamais attiré et puis il ya les
sceptiques ou l'informatique s'était
passé en outre dépassé maintenant ça va
tellement vite que deux français sur
trois se désintéressent totalement
d'internet soixante pour cent des 15 30
ans ont déjà surfé sur le web mais
l'écart se creuse avec l'âge ils ne sont
plus que 22% entre 50 et 60 ans de quoi
décevoir les prophètes qui assurer le
décollage du nombre d'internautes sur la
toile puisque mais c'est vrai que c'est
pas aussi prometteur que
les chiffres que l'on annoncé il ya
quelques années en effet pourtant depuis
six mois gérard vient tapoter le clavier
à 54 ans ce fonctionnaire espère bientôt
acheter son ordinateur
objectif complètement compte bancaire
commence en munitions humaine mais je
promets aux chrétiens de faire grand
chose pour l'instant
82% des français qui se connectent
relève on envoie du courrier
électronique 80% cherche des
informations et 24 réserve ou achètent
un enfant sur deux accès internet à
l'école et les trois faire des
adolescents savent surfer pour les
autres rassurez-vous tout n'est pas
perdu il n'est jamais trop tard pour
apprendre
les sciences